yeah
I won't let you go if yeah that makes
sense
we established
that's a scary whistle
oh patreon right patreon
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are the careful as boys on the internet
most is careful today we're going to
talk about when was the first time you
got drunk
and I mean drunk as a skunk drunk as a
skunk I was 18. 17 18. that's late isn't
it that is late yeah I never got drunk
in high school I only drank like twice
um but like very very very very very
very small amounts like a shot or two
but then when I got to college uh I was
uh invited to you know how they have
like a bunch of parties in the first
week of school oh yeah right I don't
know
um well they have a bunch of parties on
the first week of school because all the
frats want you to like rush and all that
stuff right yeah so like on Ring Road
and stuff which is at UCI this like
whole road where all the frats like
Booth up or all the different
organizations and clubs they start like
flying for [ __ ] like that right and it's
like the first week so there's this like
LTD laminated else's Asian fraternities
welcome pack of Welcome Back party right
um going to UCI is a [ __ ] ton of Asians
there it's really easy to feel
comfortable just being like okay maybe I
should go to these things and then you
end up going with like the very few
people I think I won the Victor actually
you go with the very few people that you
meet at like your freshman orientation
right
at your freshman orientation I had like
one staff member and obviously we're not
21 yet so the the Orient the staff
members that you know are older that are
kind of facilitating those things
they're cool and they're like oh yeah
we'll buy alcohol So Okay cool so you
end up just like hitting people out
bunking up with whoever is capable of
providing a fun experience even though
you're young and not even don't know
[ __ ] right and you never really drank
before and I never got drunk before so I
don't actually know what that feels so
were you kind of scared though or you're
like oh [ __ ] about to get drunk for the
first time so for any of our young
viewers who are maybe close to embarking
on such said experiments and figuring
out your drunkenness I think it's
actually really important to like learn
about those things in safer environments
yep then going into like a giant public
party with a bunch of people and you're
like the Newbie you're the young guy
nobody gives a [ __ ] about you drink by
yourself yeah figure it out do it with
your dad do it experiment find something
even if you have some Sour Apple Pucker
on your own
but even if you're underage like like
figure out responsible friends and
figure out your limits before you you're
put out on your own if you can right
that's true anyways I go out there the
bottle of I think was Jack Daniels I
probably will never forget that good
start to drink my yeah my first time
having Jack Daniels
um and we you know you just don't want
to be a [ __ ] yep yeah but the thing is
you're a [ __ ] the very first time you
drink you don't know your limits you
know if being able to take it in the
moment even if it burns that's not the
same thing as being strong with alcohol
you know handling your liquor like after
it gets in your system that's when you
actually know where your limits are but
you don't [ __ ] know that when you're
young you just think as the ball keeps
getting passed around if they can take
it I don't want to not take it it's a
very stupid boy thing to think you know
when you start dreaming anyways
we dusted the whole bottle oh before
getting into it how many how big how big
is the bottle it's just a regular like
750 milliliters but there's only like
four of us oh wow and that's a lot for a
newbie it sounds like you know what I'm
saying like if you were to just take a
quarter of a bottle yourself and your
first time drinking you don't know what
the [ __ ] is gonna happen to you I think
maybe I lasted
25 minutes and remember 25 minutes of
the party yeah classic I don't I don't
recall dancing I don't do the only blast
images I might remember is being in a
bathroom there and just throwing up
throwing up and just like that weird
feeling where you're like this is my
first major experience at college but
then there's just you're just throwing
up other people you think in your mind
two people are just judging you and [ __ ]
which they are yeah even though it
doesn't matter but they are yeah yeah
they might be taking some pictures yeah
you know and you're just [ __ ]
throwing up then next thing you know
you're like walking all hella funny
because you don't know what this feeling
is you can't [ __ ] find your friends
you start being a loser and trying to
like you know what I mean like pretend
like you know where to go or where you
belong but really you don't [ __ ]
belong anywhere you're just falling all
over the place that's a crazy [ __ ]
deep sentence yeah you don't belong
anywhere basically basically I just
[ __ ] vomited my brains out woke up
the next morning with like vomit on my
clothes and I thought to myself I was
like welcome to college and then I was
pretty much the first time getting drunk
every single time after that did you
baby step it up a baby step the [ __ ] up
you know what I'm saying like if I I
might maybe took like a shot an hour for
the next like four parties just to see
what it would actually do to me and then
finally I I would build up my tolerance
was your shirt like covered in vomit it
wasn't covered but like when it's your
first time you feel like a [ __ ] piece
of [ __ ] you know what I mean it's like
really terrible you start questioning
like everything about your life and then
the next party's next week only time you
throw a story where I wish you were
wearing Kendra's merch
[Laughter]
I don't drink so pass it on to one of
you dudes did you ever drink first time
was I was in high school and there was a
liquor store
that would sell to underage kids that we
knew of so we would go there yes still
around to this day definitely not a
BevMo definitely not a BevMo it was like
it was It was kind of in the hood a
little bit but uh now it's gentrified so
it's all good is it Country Liquor no no
no that place looks kind of shady
so we went over there I got a Four Loco
I remember it was a watermelon I didn't
really drink that much good flavor I
would always yeah out of all of them it
was probably the best it was probably
like twenty two thousand
2009 maybe 2000 times like a senior I
think in high school and at this time I
had already seen all my buddies get
drunk and kind of like lived through
them and seeing like oh yeah if you
drink too much you're gonna be [ __ ] a
piece of [ __ ] and you're gonna be thrown
up everywhere so I was like okay I'm
gonna take it real slow
so I started drinking and like dude it
was
it wasn't really anything that notable I
don't think I got that drunk I just
remember feeling good for you yeah like
I just took it real slow
and I wish I had a cool story but I had
a great time it was fun
um
[Laughter]
this one really sucks oh no okay so I
was I think I was 16 or 17 and I lied to
my parents and I said I'm going to sleep
over my friend's house our plan was to
drive to Santa Barbara because there
were all these parties it's beautiful oh
I love Santa and so I went with her and
this guy that she was dating he had a
car and he was going to drive us we went
to the store we got like two liters of
like Hawaiian Punch and poured maybe 70
of it out and filled it with like any
kind of vodka and tequila that's that
Jungle Juice yeah okay so she and I are
in the back seat he's driving us there
um we're working out yeah not hard yeah
just adding to it yeah
so she and I probably finished like a
good good 60 of those two leaders he
finished he was driving too this is
really dumb oh [ __ ] this could have
ended really bad that's a long drive too
yeah so by the time exactly so by the
time we got to Santa Barbara it was
already Nightfall we were hammered we
finally found the place where the
parties were happening we found our
parking spot and by the time we got out
we were so drunk that we got lost and we
were like [ __ ] this let's not go to the
party anymore had to find the car
I found the car led us back to the car
and we had booked a hotel room that
night because I was gonna come back to
my parents house in the morning like in
the afternoon
and so we got into the car like okay
[ __ ] this like we're way too drunk and
we're gonna go to the hotel the hotel's
like maybe five minutes away so we are
about three minutes out to the hotel we
get pulled over
oh no we get pulled over this is tragic
yeah next story sucks
let me take it
um I got good stories I got this
we get pulled over
um and the cops come out and they give
him a breathalyzer test and she and I
are so drunk
um obviously we didn't know the laws at
that time like we could have denied the
breathalyzer test we didn't I blew like
a .18 or something oh
congrats got it he got congrats well at
least you weren't driving yeah at least
you weren't driving yeah so he got
arrested he got a DUI
she and I both got misdemeanors the cops
are lesbianism yeah
a little bit more we'll break that down
and we'll let you go if yeah that makes
sense
that's a scary whistle
oh patreon right patreon
nope so uh the cops drove us back to the
hotel
I was so upset
um because they gave us a misdemeanor so
I have it in my pocket and I'm like what
the [ __ ] am I gonna like what am I gonna
do how am I gonna explain this to my how
are you gonna get home yeah how do you
get fat I called a friend and my friend
said okay cool I'm picking you both up
you drove three hours oh got us what a
friend what a friend a man absolutely
friend
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I get home he drops her off he drops me
off I get home at like 8 A.M and I I get
inside I go straight to my bed because
at this point I'm still drunk I'm still
[ __ ] up I'm still throwing up my
family didn't realize that I was home
and so I slept till like maybe the mid
afternoon almost evening at this point
woke up was like well I might as well
get this over with
walk downstairs and said hey I lied and
put the misdemeanor on the table you're
a [ __ ] gangster damn dude go watch
those goddamn rocks
I got more Pebbles yeah go watch those
[ __ ] they're twice as big you see the
dirt on the ground get the dirt off the
ground this was after so maybe yeah that
was after
um and so the worst part about it was
because I got a misdemeanor in that City
I had to go to AAA classes in that City
foreign
so my mom was pissed because I didn't
have a car at the time so she's like
really you did this now I have to drive
you to this AAA meeting three times to
get this like cleared and yeah that was
that's my [ __ ] should ask your buddy
to take you dude yeah
I'll tell you for sure yeah
you want to get dinner after are you
still kind of tired those are the dates
he's like I remember when I went on a
date with Colleen that guy go that guy
looks himself in the mirror in the
bathroom he's like [ __ ] here you're a
[ __ ] hero man yeah I'm a [ __ ] here
dude your mom have to drive you back to
Santa Barbara three times three times
but I remember being in the meeting and
sitting there with with these people who
are like actually alcoholics and older
like and older and like tearing their
story and you're 16. well the person
who's like teaching class was actually
pretty cool because they're like this is
what you do to to help yourself if you
are you're drunk like the types of foods
you eat the things that you get it's
nice that's hella used I would have
[ __ ] I needed that a long time ago
stories of the people in the room and
how they got caught they're like how did
you get here this one guy was like
running from the cops and went to go
climb a fence but it was electric oh my
God no way and he had no hands while
he's telling the story and so like he
tried to his hair is still straight up
before I tell a story my hair straight
up it has nothing to do with the story
I'm just I'm a gel user I'm a gel user
yeah yeah L.A looks like your mom
yelling at you the whole way there every
time no she was I think she was so upset
that she had like nothing to say to me
after the initial conversation of me
putting the misdemeanor on the table so
we suck at Short over the off the
records um we might as well make this a
long one dude you know what I mean uh I
might as well we're too good for me
we're just too good at it we're in this
Zone you know it's the flu game every
time apparently it's because we got
Colleen's 20 stories yeah yeah that was
a great story by the way are you done
I'm sorry no that's it yeah should I
tell my story again I think I should get
another shot no you're done I don't want
to hear about you anymore
[Laughter]
you know what and I I felt fine I was
good Nick proved me wrong we're done
[Music]